hey youtubers it's Charlie so a lot of
you guys requested I do a Game of
Thrones video about all the characters
that are missing on the show right now
now these include characters that just
got dropped from season five or
characters that rode off into the mists
and just we haven't seen forever there's
always a lot of debate as to when a
characters dead when they're not dead if
they might secretly be another character
so let's just get started I'm gonna
start with like the biggest and just
worked my way down the list real quick
reminder to new round of the giveaway
starts now all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video and just careful for
spoilers for everything that's happened
on the show so far
moving to the iron Isles what's going on
with the Ironborn where they at
we're talking like Balon Greyjoy in yara
on the TV show balance probably still
chilling out in the sea stone chair yara
we last saw trying to rescue Theon but
she took off because he'd gone
full-blown reek my baby brother is dead
the good thing about the Ironborn even
though their plot seemingly got dropped
for all of season five is that it seems
like they're casting euron greyjoy and
will probably get a truncated version of
the Kingsmoot from the books if you
haven't read the books you don't know
what the King's mood is let's just say
it's a gathering to choose a leader it
goes down very differently in the books
there's a lot more characters we'll
probably see a smaller version of it on
the show I'm not expecting them to cast
fake Tyrion I know a lot of people you
don't shake their fist in the air the
way I think of the kings mood is it's
kind of like a small Ironborn specific
version of a Great Council now a great
council is when all the Lords of
Westeros meet to decide who gets to be
the next king if that needs to happen
since they got its conquest there's only
been a couple of them but it was rumored
that Rhaegar Targaryen was planning on
calling the Lords to make a great
council so that he could supplant his
father the Mad King too bad he ended up
dying at the Battle of the Trident well
we'll never learn how that went down
but moving our way down the list Benjen
stark everybody wants to know where the
hell of Benjen Stark is he secretly
another character so I will say right
away that I do not think that he is
Daario I don't think that he's anybody
else he's still gonna be bench and Stark
and know he's not dead
Martin has made it very clear that he is
not specified that he is dead yet which
just means that he's out wandering
around somewhere we also found out that
he's not cold hands what I think is
gonna happen is that he's gonna show up
again during bran storyline now the
actor that plays benjin Joseph Mali he
got cast on another show so if his
it's difficult to have him back just
because he's busy doing other stuff but
they could always bring him back in a
future season there are a lot of people
wondering if he might have been the
night's king from episode 8 and season 5
if that had been the case the facial
features probably would have been made
to look a lot more like benjin the as it
stands the actor that's playing the
night's game the real-life actor doesn't
look anything like him so until Martin
proves otherwise and wins a winter
benjin is still running around in the
north maybe he might even come back with
the real Horn of winter next on the list
Rickon in OSHA both still totally alive
in the books they're hiding out on the
island of skagos now the TV show might
change that they might just be hiding
out with stark loyalists don't forget to
remember that the North remembers so
they'll probably a lot of people in
season 6 they'll be sympathetic to Sansa
one of them like small John umber or one
of the other lords in the north might be
hiding Rickon OSHA or they could be on
ska ghosts like they are in the books it
stands to reason that the TV show would
keep them a little bit closer though
don't forget that they are casting
multiple northern Lords we're gonna see
a lot of stuff going on up in the North
next on the list bran Hodor Meera in the
three-eyed raven now we know they recast
max von sydow is the three-eyed Raven so
that means they're probably planning
some pretty big scenes with those
characters if they wanted such a big
actor they're all still totally alive
the only reason that the work part of
season 5 is that their story was so far
ahead of all the other characters
stories in the books that the story that
season 5 was telling just didn't need
them they weren't necessary for the plot
we're kind of fuzzy about the timeline
between the end of season 4 in the end
of season 5 but I'd say that it's less
than a year so bran has probably just
been training with the three-eyed Raven
in that time so that when we pick up in
season 6 and we see him he'll be using
his green site if you don't know a green
site is it's kind of like giving someone
power over nature working is
transferring your consciousness to
another animal green site is like way
way more powerful than that but it is
really cool and might give us some of
our flashbacks that's what people are
talking about when they're talking about
weirwood flashbacks next on the list
Gendry last seen rowing away from
Dragonstone down to King's Landing
that's that's where he was supposed to
be going I would say unless he gets
picked up by a slaving ship or some
other ship he's probably still headed to
King's Landing I know a lot of people
really hope that he shows up in Arya
storyline in the East but Arya
probably gonna be coming back to
Westeros anyway so if they're gonna meet
back up it'll probably be after she
comes back to Westeros moving next on
the list the Brotherhood without banners
last seen running around the Riverlands
they're pretty much doing the same thing
but beric Dondarrion the after the play
sim also cast on a bunch of other shows
so it's probably gonna be difficult to
bring him back we might not see him
again they have cast a group of
characters that sounds a lot like the
Brotherhood without banners so they may
have just recast some roles and we see a
version of them in season six Brienne
just seems like she's gonna be running
into said group which happens in the
books so they might be combining that
plotline with the North remembers
plotline because that I don't think that
Brienne is gonna venture too far away
from where she thinks Sansa is going and
remember if she didn't see Sansa escape
so she probably still thinks that she's
at Winterfell
so Brotherhood without banners is
probably one of those storylines that's
gonna get changed quite a bit and no I
don't think that we're gonna see Lady
Stoneheart there were a lot of rumors
about that they have since been debunked
next on the list Edmure Tully in the
blackfish now ed Muir has been cast on
another show he's actually on Outlander
right now so we probably won't see him
again but as of right now he's still a
prisoner of the phrase they have not
killed him yet but the problem with the
blackfish is is that his plot line in
the books gets tied up with Jaime and
it's in the Riverlands and Jaime went
somewhere totally different in season
five so they might circle back around
like if Jaime goes back to the
Riverlands we could totally see the
blackfish again but I'm not expecting it
the way goes down in the books is that
he holds up inside Riverrun it holds a
couple Lannister cousins hostage so
Jaime has to go try to get them back but
if they decide not to do that they could
always bring the blackfish back through
the North remembers storyline it just
sounds like the big revenge arc next
season is going to be the north remember
so like any character that is loyal to
the Starks will be part of that North
remembers storyline I've already done a
video about the Hound technically he's
not missing
he just we're not sure if he's dead or
not Stannis Baratheon pretty sure that
he's dead on the show I'm not I'm not
considering him missing George R Martin
recently said that he is definitely
alive but only in the books now remember
there are a lot of characters in the
books that are still alive that are dead
on the show so alive or dead in the
books doesn't necessarily correlate to
alive or dead on the TV show and I know
a couple people were asking about sir
pounce sir pounce still alive like still
running around
the castle he's still around in the
books too but the producers and some of
the directors said that yeah it like he
were probably never gonna see him again
on the TV show they said that working
with the cat like working with the
animal was just like one of the most
difficult things ever like it wouldn't
behave at all so you guys let me know
who's your favorite missing character
and when do you think that we'll see
them again so what's gonna happen next
is they're just dropping a couple huge
DC TV bombs we're probably gonna get a
couple trailers this week so I'm gonna
try to work all that stuff in I still
have a Walking Dead Q&A to do but I'm
still gonna do a game of Thrones Q&A so
try to get that up by tomorrow at least
by Thursday don't forget you guys can
totally leave special requests for bonus
videos in the comments below my next
bonus video will be the post like Sunday
or Monday depending on like what kind of
log jam happens with videos this weekend
every once in a while like something
really crazy happens now the TV's coming
back so while you guys wait for all that
stuff you can click here to learn all
about the night's king in azor Ahai and
you can click here to learn all about
the Tower of joy thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you